[Musique]
franchement on est la risée du monde
enfin ils nous auront tout fait ces
terres qui l'ont raté l'étape des
masques je trouve que cette politique de
vaccination qui n'en est pas une puisque
est une déroute la plus totale
car tous s'accordent sur un point la
vaccination ne va pas assez vite
seulement 352 français ont reçu une dose
pour l'instant on ne fait pas le bilan
d'une politique vaccinale six jours
après le début de la politique vaccinale
pour autant je pense qu'il faut
raisonner non mais j'en période de crise
j'avais coupé jean mathis et barry parce
que cette phrase je les lui comme tout
le monde dans la bouche de gabriella
talent sont des éléments de langage on
ne fait pas un bilan de politique
vaccinale après six jours quand des pays
de population comparable comme par
exemple l'allemagne qui a vacciné déjà
180 mille personnes israël qui a déjà
vacciné 13 % de sa population en chine
aux états en chine aux états unis on a
déjà vacciné dizaines de millions de
personnes et que nous on s'aperçoit
qu'on est pas prêt franchement je trouve
ça honteux ça veut dire que
contrairement à l'allemagne qui est
souvent cité en exemple de comparaison
on n'a pas pour cette première phase
ouvert dès vaccinodromes où beaucoup de
personnes peuvent venir se faire
vacciner
on concentre sur les maisons de retraite
qu'on fait donc venir le vaccin dans les
plus de 8000 je crois à maisons de
retraite en france que ça prend un peu
plus de temps on prend un peu plus de
temps pour recueillir le consentement
pour à ces personnes nous espérons que
nous serons capables de vacciner des
dizaines de millions de personnes au
cours des trois prochains mois
outre-rhin les vaccinodromes sont au
coeur de la stratégie sanitaire près de
189 mille personnes ont déjà été
vaccinées
ce matin c'est le président de la
république qui dans le journal du
dimanche
pousse un coup de gueule il faut lire
comme ça oui des citations du chef de
l'état nous sommes sur un rythme de
promenade en famille ce n'est à la
hauteur ni du moment ni des français
voilà les propos rapportés par le jdd
parfois le fable de la fontaine du
lièvre et la tortue s'appliquera
peut-être à notre à ce que nous sommes
en train de faire c'est à dire que nous
sommes en train de fermer la jungle et
marées plus lentement mais il ya quelque
chose de très structuré qui est en train
de se mettre en place
il est évident qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
accélérer maintenant si je suis
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir actionner 25
millions de français dit si elles
étaient 26 millions france à l'été
opération communication des autorités
depuis quelques heures avec un message
la vaccination s'accélère les personnels
de plus de 50 ans de l'ap-hp commence à
être vaccinés dans plusieurs hôpitaux de
paris il se devait de montrer l'exemple
devant les objectifs et sur les réseaux
sociaux le président de l'ordre des
médecins ou ce chef des urgences je pas
d'antenne qu'on poussait mais mes
cheveux sont pas devenus verts et puis
bon ça va
le vaccin protège plus qu' aucun vaccin
ne protège de la vaccin contre la grippe
il ya deux ans protégé à 38% et il
refait pourtant là on a un vaccin qui
protège à 95% donc ma réponse à des
liens ils ont menti sur les masses non
mais sur les réacteurs sur quoi dans les
vaccins alors sur evans et ils ont dit
que la vaccination ne serait pas
obligatoire
or monsieur castex le premier ministre a
fait passer en catimini à quelques jours
de noël quand même c'est pas très à
l'aise pas très élégant à trois jours de
noël
un projet de loi dans lequel il était
clairement écrit noir sur blanc que
l'accès à un certain nombre de lieux
vieux public par exemple ou de lieux
privés pourraient être dans les
prochains mois dans ce contexte un
couvre-feu deux heures plus tôt que le
reste du pays est entrée en vigueur hier
soir dans 15 départements
essentiellement dans le nord-est et le
sud-est du pays
la bourgogne franche comté la moselle
les ardennes le jura ou quand les
alpes-maritimes
il s'appelait yvonne huisne et loïc
riesser deux militaires français décédés
au matin du 2 janvier dans la région de
ménaka dans l'est du mali alors en
mission
leur véhicule a explosé au contact d'un
engin explosif improvisé
un troisième militaire a été blessé ses
jours ne sont pas en danger
la ministre des armées a fait part de sa
profonde tristesse
la france a perdu deux de ses enfants il
les incarne l'honneur et la bravoure des
huit sarde chamborans mes pensées vont à
leurs familles
ces attaques interviennent alors que la
france envisage une réduction des
effectifs de la force barkan depuis 2000
13 50 soldats français ont été tués au
sahel